une seule seconde à markov malcolm
hartley coeurs à vif avec drazic anita
c'est à hawaii police d'état
je suis allé à hawaï uniquement pour la
série hawaii police d'état 10 6 s et la
révélation de l'an dernier alors j'ai
tenté black mirror
colombo mais je suive non je suis pas
sur grand chose sur ma femme dont un
archos la base aucun des deux regardez 2
j'ai beaucoup aimé narco ce sera un
archos marco j'adorerais comme michael à
gaubert
l'amour âgées en effet une série sur la
tv le monde de la teom est une femme
pourquoi ça marche pourquoi c'est
compliqué j'ai une passion pour les drag
queen je suis fan de larrau paul la
grace
ça serait sur les drag queen sur jean de
laur maladroit et attachants comme moi
rachel râches
c'est la plus belle elle est légère tout
en étant profonde superficiel mais pas
trop ces j'adore
[Musique]
deux accords regardiez ce golf wissous
et l'as tonnerre impitoyable tanins
amicalement autres attentats à la bombe
et notre belle famille à voir ce soir
est de vivre toute espèce tu n'es jamais
la vie
maggie stefan maggie voilà maggie
l'homme qui va être milliards jean ratez
pas un sommet les mystères de l'ouest
avec jane soit seul prince de bel air
cette maison
[Musique]
merçi crif et nicolas arrêtez un peu de
jeux ont ce don mc a fait je vous
attends devant le garage festival au nom
elle est fermée
[Musique]